dos años después de ese marzo de 2020
que seguro nunca vamos a olvidar estamos
en una situación radicalmente distinta
en lo que respecta a la lucha contra el
commit 19 porque porque tenemos muchas
más herramientas que en ese momento
donde la única herramienta para combatir
la pandemia era esas cuarentenas que se
impusieron en gran parte del mundo
tenemos por ejemplo mayores medicamentos
mejores tratamientos tenemos las vacunas
una herramienta clave en la lucha contra
esta enfermedad y sobre todo también lo
que tenemos es más conocimiento al
inicio de la pandemia apenas sabíamos
cómo se contagiaba el cob y 19 por
ejemplo desinfecta vamos todo mientras
que ahora sabemos que este virus se
transmite sobre todo a través del aire
eso nos permite tomar muchas mejores
precauciones combatir mejor este virus
también desarrollar mejores tratamientos
y sobre todo algo que va a perdurar
además después de la pandemia es todo el
conocimiento científico que ha acumulado
la población sobre inmunología sobre
epidemiología sobre vacunas por ejemplo
no una información que nos da la
posibilidad de ser mucho más críticos
también a la hora de cómo nos cuidamos
como protegemos al resto de la sociedad
y como consideramos que están
protegiéndonos también los gobiernos con
sus medidas sanitarias sin embargo dos
años después hay una elección que parece
que todavía no hemos aprendido y es la
que nadie está a salvo hasta que todo el
mundo esté a salvo a qué nos referimos
pues que en el continente africano
todavía hay un 19% solo de la población
vacunada con al menos una dosis y ahora
ya está ahora ya deberíamos saber que
hasta que eso no se solucione nadie
estará a salvo de la pandemia